cent dix mille personnes étaient au
stade de france pour 75 mille places
donc 35000 anglais sans billet ou avec
des faux billets étaient autour du stade
alors il ya une confusion dans un
chiffre aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient 2800
faux billets ont été scannées nuls votre
question vous la changer oui donc les
gens ont dit deux mille huit cents
billets ont été scannées ce n'est pas 30
milles mais ce n'est pas du tout le même
chiffre les billets scanner qui ont été
recensés comme faut c'est une partie de
tous les faux billets tous n'ont pas été
scannés donc on maintient nos chiffres
on maintient nos chiffres ce n'est pas
la faute des banlieusards c'est la faute
des anglais nul que s'ils ont
massivement truquée avec de la fausse
huriez tri l'événement qui devait être
protégé samedi soir sur les mollahs haro
sur les anglais monsieur bardella donc
en fait si est des touristes qui des
supporters qui sont fait agresser piller
voler les voitures etc c'est de la faute
des anglais alors sur les anglais la
scène sonia alors avant de louer je le
dis très respectueusement là vous faites
de la politique vous ne parlez pas de
chiffres et il ya eu six comparution
immédiate aujourd'hui si jugement en
comparution immédiate ce sont des
majeures qui viennent de toute
l'ile-de-france qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la seine saint denis ou qui ont à
voir pas plus que vous et moi que
d'autres avec la seine saint denis hier
geler la scène samedi à ça monsieur
c'est faux non mais je pense que vous
êtes complètement déconnecté déconnecté
des images hier j'étais au commissariat
de police de saint denis un policier
nous a dit sur les quarante et une
interpellation quarante et une garde à
vue il y avait 31 31 kandestin faire 31
une personne en situation irrégulière
qui m'a t-il dit probable' probable ans
venait de la porte de la chapelle il ya
deux sujets il ya le sujet de la
billetterie et des supporters anglais
qui était assez à l'entrée c'est pas ça
le sujet ce n'est pas sale affaire la
faire c'est les violences qu'il ya eu
ensuite sur les supporters et dont le
parisien d'ailleurs ce matin fait un
très bon rappelle qu'il ya des gens qui
ont été volés ont été agressés ont été
dépouillés les voitures ont été cassées
on est venu prendre les valises à
l'intérieur s'est pas séparé ces gens là
ces gens là ces délinquants là venaient
des sites et aux alentours à mêmes de la
porte de la chêneraie pas de vibrer je
voulais
la fox juste pour terminer donc tout le
monde s'accorde à dire la vérité il ya
deux personnes qui disent le contraire
gérald darmanin et gilles verdez alors s
opère deux personnes encore sur le sujet
alors en vacances turp les chinois pour
la ville de pripiat ou celle qui est
président du département de
seine-saint-denis donnez-nous votre
votre bourse a fait ça fait 25 ans que
le stade de france il est en
seine-saint-denis c'est la troisième
finale de la ligue des champions il la
semaine dernière il y avait un concert
qui a réuni cent mille personnes coupe
du monde de rugby finale de l'euro 2016
visiblement visiblement il ya eu un
problème d'organisation spécifique mais
avec votre argumentaire sur bardella en
fait c'est darmanin et le préfet de
police l'allemand ils peuvent dormir
tranquille quoi ils n'ont aucun compte à
rendre parce que si à chaque fois qu'il
ya un événement de cette nature vous
découvrez qui à quelques centaines de
délinquants qui viennent pourrir les
choses mais oui malheureusement c'est le
cas il ya un certain nombre de
délinquants mais franchement c'est d'une
mauvaise foi absolue
en plus d'être du pur électoralisme et
de la récupération politique de dire que
finalement ça serait de la
responsabilité de la seine saint denis
et de ses habitants donc ce soir là il
ya eu un problème d'organisation
spécifique et on peut regarder les il y
en a il ya de multiples raisons à cela
peut-être un certain nombre de faux
billets peut-être des problèmes de
défaillance du filtrage peut-être des
consignes aux forces de l'ordre qui ont
certainement pas été donnée correctement
on va voir ça vous rappelle pas quelques
gestion de manifestations avec des
gilles et je voulais l'appeler non moi
je dis pas c'est la faute de lait des
policiers mais par contre je demande des
comptes à monsieur l'allemand
d'accord parce que la terre entière la
terre entière demande des comptes au
gouvernement mais vous vous demander des
comptes à la seine saint denis alors il
parle puisque même les anglais auront
conscience et dire que c'est de leur
faute c'est une histoire
risque et l'incident diplomatique avec
la grande-bretagne en accusant liverpool
et en créant des tensions diplomatiques
plutôt qu'avec les quelques délinquants
la scène tandis que je savais que
l'accusé les ombres et j'accuse et les
emplois et sachez qu il hier on m'a
refusé mon billet sur l'eurostar
joe jordan bart et la technique
extrêmement sérieux
réunir vers
chez
moi je pense que gilles verdez et encore
une fois mais complètement à côté de la
plaque est dans un déni gravissime alors
il s'agit absolument pas de stigmatiser
le 9 3 en revanche pardonnez-moi mais
darmanin est complètement à côté de la
plaque il demande d'ailleurs où mots
comme un arracheur de dents et michael
good wife il va falloir qu'ils aient une
enquête une enquête précise le times a
démonté la version 2 darmanin fiennes
tous les médias du monde entier veulent
torpiller darmanin mes sources proches
du pouvoir donc de macron dix bateaux
elma qu il est absolument du président
il en fait ils le maintiennent en vie
parce que ils le maintiennent en
assistance respiratoire parce qu'il ya
les élections législatives dans deux
semaines le mans mais aussi non ils
sautent parce que darmana il veut pas
stigmatiser veut pas dire qu'il ya des
problèmes aujourd'hui avec la banlieue
avec certains avec certaines pas du tout
où je le stigmate histoire avec certains
groupes les anglais n'y sont pour rien
c'est pas vrai pas du tout parce que
cette histoire de fausses billetteries
gilles tu dis ô combien 40 ongles et ce
n'importe quoi comment tu sais qu'avec
40 mille faux billets mais comment tu
sais mais c'est la fédération française
les anglais se sont prévisibles
c'est peu dire vous êtes au fil des
vestiaires la fed et cyril vous étiez
sur place était un donateur des
doublages étiez vous étiez sur les
relations france vous étiez petite
minute stéphane séva nous louis où j'ai
laissé sur place au classement moi
j'étais sur place hockey à quelques
minutes du coup d'envoi j'ai tout le
monde a vu qu'il y avait des un nombre
considérable de spectateurs qui étaient
encore dehors j'ai réussi à rentrer
j'avais le sentiment que le stade était
déjà plein donc à l'évidence il y avait
autour du stade bien plus de spectateurs
moi je dis pas tu irais pas qu'un très
petit mais attendait qu'ils sont mais
c'est ce que je viens de voir que je
suis en train de vous dire donc mais à
l'évidence il y avait bien plus de
spectateurs à l'extérieur que la
capacité du stade elle pouvait et soria
contenu 2012 en vrai faux billets et ne
sais pas larry à long terme de monsieur
darmana
ronzier trente mille calories et d'un
essai qui à 120 c où ces gens là mais
larry haylor méritons bien la rue après
multi l'ont été un petit tube de
problèmes et faisceaux facile de pointer
du doigt les quelques centaines il y en
a oui il ya des saints il ya quelques
petites centaines de voyous qui sont
venus pour rien alors si j'allais voir
principale mesure est le sujet principal
c'est que aujourd'hui dans notre pays où
il faudrait s'interroger sur la doctrine
d'emploi des forces de l'ordre quant aux
consignes qui sont données pour jérémy
qui ont été déjà exact absolue les
vaches problème c'est à l'anticipation
localisation exacte dans l'anticipation
l'organisation du mans qui est normal de
les sables de sary api les revendre de
lorenzo qui l'incombé dans la vie il
faut le dire non gilles mais non mais il
y avait une note c'est vrai delà de la
division nationale contre le
hooliganisme disait et à 50000 ya cinq
ans le bilan anglais qui vont venir avec
de faux billets ou sans billet l'anglais
xas voilà des anglais ça ça a été
négligée mais quand vous avez
franchement mokhtar est là et les a vus
quand vous avez des aides je vais vous
dire moi ce sont des hordes de sauvages
d'anglais raciste s'ils veulent garder
la roue des anglais les anonymes comme
ça foutez pas le sujet qui est de
conquérir juppé détaillant de vue qu'à
quarante mille
40 mille anglais et yann calas de
britanniques en garde à vue a eu à voilà
il ya quarante
mille anglais tu cours est vaste et
leurs dates de concours de dessin n'est
pas le 19 juin
sur ecms et moi
je réclame une enquête par exemple sur
les effectifs de police je veux savoir
je viens de savoir combien y avait des
fixeurs de mots l'isthme autour du stade
de france y est souvent bien il y en
avait sur les champs elysées combien il
y en avait à nation pourquoi les
supporters sont arrivés si tard au stade
de france y compris il n'était pas utile
monsieur et
[Musique]
bienne par rapport à monsieur bardella
c'est que là vous êtes en train de dire
cet événement raté montrent qu'un
problème de délinquant ni un problème
avec la seine-saint-denis et akon
seine-saint-denis laissez moi vous
donner les chiffres vous avez des
milliers ou des dizaines de minutes
d'anglais qui ont fait que cet événement
a été un échec monumental est d'accord
des tortillas mais laissez moi juste
finir une ce jour répondre eia voilà il
ya 48 garde à vue dont 15 majeur
mineurs leurs gardes à vue ont été
levées dont vous faites une affaire
d'état 2,48 garde à vue mais six
personnes jugées aujourd'hui en
correctionnelle pour des vols et ça vous
en faites une avril d'état je veux dire
tous les événements suivants
6 personnes et supporters qu'ils sont
fait agresser de cette manière ils sont
pas près de revenir en france ayant un
haut gradé de la gendarmerie qui dit ce
matin à visage couvert dans médiapart il
dit les déclarations du ministre
d'ailleurs son délirant 40000 supporters
à l'extérieur c'est l'équivalent du parc
des princes plein c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est ce qui a eu lieu après le
problème c'est pas la billetterie le
problème c'est que eh oui je dis qu'ils
impriment avec la seine-saint-denis
parce que ce qu'ont subi les supporters
en rentrant chez eux n'est même procédé
mamouni les gens qui sont joints j'ai
agressé qu'on était attaqués y compris
des femmes qu'ils se comptent de
violence sexuelle c'est ce que subissent
tous les jours les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis et monsieur marges et
la drogue plutôt désolant alors la
baptiser les
messieurs bardés la thématisation
bardella plutôt que parler de la
sécurité sur les plateaux de télévision
et de vous faire élire comme eurodéputés
retroussé vous les manches et je lui ai
amené monsieur natal est mal préparé mon
élan vous nécessitez bien sûr vous avez
mal préparé vous aider vous faire élire
en seine-saint-denis retrouve ses vos
manches et occupez-vous de la sécurité
si c'est vous
et moi j'ai pas de le soir monsieur prix
les plus modestes de ce pays c'est les
plus mortelles combien de temps mais là
c'est idiot vous gêne leçon à recevoir
de vous c'est ben merde villani le maire
de saint denis le nouveau maire de saint
louis depuis deux ans il a triplé les
effectifs de police municipale
il est en train de fécos gris anglais
des caméras de vidéosurveillance donc
franchement bonne âme et conviendront
que vous avez président la
seine-saint-denis chute tel résultat
mais vous vous nous a franchement la
nuit de puiser être ingénieur vous ne
vivez pas moi j'ai une j ai pas j'y suis
pas seulement déçu parce que j'ai été
menacé vos amis que vous couvrez moi qui
cela tu seulement né où j'ai pas
seulement grandi moi j'y vis encore et
je viens la courneuve donc vos leçons je
sais que vous vivez à la courneuve rire
ça que se déroule son moral jour là
et non il n'y a pas de problème de
sécurité en scène messi mais nous aussi
coltine vous vous en parlez vous avez vu
votre bible vous en parler à bruxelles
et sur les plates vous avez vu autre
bilan se demande concrètement et ont
réglé prier on essaye de régler les
problèmes vous réglez voyez vous nous
demander des comptes à nous vous en
demandez pas darmanin mais qu'elle
demande et le joli ou celles demandées
lui à l'allemand et quelle est sa
doctrine d'emploi des forces de police
dans notre pays combien y avait des
effectifs de police ans au stade de
france plutôt que sur les champs elysées
pourquoi les causes les forces de
l'ordre étaient laissés seuls sans
aucune consigne ça mais en fait vous
êtes ono poseurs incarne aron thiel km à
monsieur entendu marc darman a
représenté le gouvernement porte parole
vous disiez avant j'ai maintenant ses
représentants vous aurez ca de grade non
je voulais simplement dire alors comment
se fait-il indochine justement on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure de chine qu'à
indochine le groupe à ses concerts qui
la concerne et 93 mille personnes pas un
pur indochine temps là dedans pas un
problème et un air seine-saint-denis
alors alors voulais pas le parallèle
vous est alors de la coupe de fruitiers
ce qui se met à chanter quoi
des problèmes latents ne l'ont jamais
dit gc a pas non plus de problème il ya
eu des promesses qu'on comprenait mon
processus intellectuel ajoutant toshiba
c'est pas n'importe quoi la finale
pareil a pas eu de problème non plus ils
font quoi les problèmes à l'excès les
anglais je vous dis les objets c'est à
dire j'adore j'adore l onglet gellé
soleil c'est l'essor toute façon qu'est
ce qui va nous arriver nous on regarde
pas on s'en fou dit que c'est des
anglais j'ai gardé lasser les anglais
dire ça c'est parce
qu'ils aient vu les sangles et c'était
pierre s'est répété en boucle ah oui
mais je vous dis comme ça ils sont
tranquilles et là mais vous vous le
saloir vous le voyez pas de traverser
votre seul argument c'est la scène c'est
un élève en plein milieu d'une annoncé
votre soupe c'est la folie c'est
l'allemand qui est des hommes l'érection
les appels
en vérité et votre question
habituellement vérité les avis sont
unanimes est devenue une zone de non
droit voilà vous savez qu'un autre droit
la loi des dealers c'est la loi des
trafics de droit anglais où il ya plus
qu'une femme qui sort d'une cité
habillées en jupes pourquoi êtes vous
m'avez soirée est ce que ces agressions
sans leur aide et ont atteint grand isle
et de refrains et essayer de régler les
problèmes et
mesquine expliquer ce qui s'est passé le
laisser passer mais auriez dû touchera
des pelotons 10 et les anglais ou dit
s'être écartés d'accès les anglais
avaient maps et les engrais les anglais
pour moi il y accéder sans club et si
vous voulez mais match vous avez raison
mais je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
vous pour moi c'est une multi touch
raison sinon vous avez peut-être raison
mais moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec vous pour moi c'est une multitude
de causé beaucoup les enfants mais non
mais pas du tout il ya eu plein de
problèmes d'organisation en amont ils
avaient été prévenus qu'ils avaient des
faux billets pas du tout dans le chiffre
de ce qu annonce gilles verdez qui
encore une fois colporte une fake news
donc a eu plein de problèmes d'aig le
rer b en
orienter les ont orientés du r vrd qui
ont dû marcher les d'étranglement non
non moi là il ya eu plein trouvait donc
darmanin à force de ne pas dire les
choses excusez moi pour moi il fait une
faute politique majeure parce qu'il ne
veut pas se prononcer il veut pas dire
qu'il ya des problèmes par rapport à
cette organisation et moi
personnellement je pense qu'il va sauter
en plein vol mais il ya quand même un
pro il ya eu quand même aussi il faut
pas le nier un fan de faux billets à
wissant lieu quand l'uefa dit nous ne
voulons plus de billets
liverpool a réclamé l'édition de billets
billet papier donc oui oui il ya eu des
problèmes avec les pme je suis pas
capable de dire combien les personnes
circulant à vide g20 ils sont à chaque
fois même à les regarder au 7 août et
l'artiste contre les anglais a dit l'un
et moi il ya des hiérarchies dans le
racisme la douane on vient d'ouvrir
givre insiste contre les anglais où il
dit c'est la faute des anglais c'est des
anglais c'est la débandade je
voulais et attendais oui on va dire que
vous allez nous dire quelque chose c'est
peut-être que vous dormez c'est renan
luce
tout le week-end tout le week-end dans
la presse britannique et dans la presse
espagnole journalistes britanniques et
espagnols qui étaient présents sur place
leurs témoignages sont hallucinants une
journaliste espagnole dit j'ai assisté à
beaucoup de finale de la ligue des
champions et à roanne pas ce qui ce
grâce au stade de france je n'avais
jamais vu ça nous non plus à des groupes
de quatre heures au cours du xxi d'adp
qui attaque et vol uni ont suivi et un
journaliste britannique parle de gang
des barbares des journalistes arrivant
on se dit c'est ça
et malgré
un autre monde c'est hallucinant aller
aujourd'hui parce que ça fait un si long
sur des résistants avec séoul alors vous
êtes complètement perret
cette coupe c'est bien mais
[Applaudissements]
les images à l'agresseur c'est de la
faute des personnes et familles en
glacis vous choque pas plus les êtres
les familles anglaises qui avaient
détecté des matchs
et de joie qui évidemment comme demain
évidemment amélie l'intérieur est en
cours des temps mais vous regardiez
qu'il aurait dû ressembler mais c'est
mais vous vous regarde vous ne me
regarde alors mais nie pas qu'il ya des
délinquants mais cet événement sujet il
n'y pas qu'ils aient des voiliers sont
évidemment ça le sujet que vous et ces
voyous l'aller qui ont des voyous
saint-amour il a vidé à néant la scène
slam vous pensez que les quelques
centaines ou cinquantaine de voyous qui
sont venues pourrir là c'est très grave
ce cas il est passé mais c'est très
grave mais oui vous pensez que la
gestion par la police de cet événement
c'est pas grave moi je considère que
c'est grave et chômage de vendre des
chars c'est déjà miraculeux entend voir
exactement semerad j'ai le don qu'il est
l'anglais l'allemand et à gérald ans et
les anglais bien
tendu c'est une affaire d'état parce que
monsieur darmanin va être auditionné par
le sénat lors l'une de libération voilà
ils
ont su faire ce constat de france dames
anna ruffec le droit s'explique devant
le sénat donc voilà veut dire qu'il est
à moi j'ai une question pour vous si
vous permettez monsieur bardella bardé
d'un pour moi les anglais je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi dans le stade dans
l'onglet quoi donc je vous pose une
question le staff sait quoi vous dites
les anglais les anglais si c'est des
gens qui habitent de l'autre côté de la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
seine les anglais qui sont responsables
et ils sont responsables d'une chose
dont je voudrais vous parler à
l'intérieur du stade il était donc assis
sur les escaliers puisque les anglais
c'est les anglais les escaliers
ce qui était dangereux pour la sécurité
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de billets
numérotés vu que c'était des faux
billets il certains ont réussi à entrer
d'accord eh bien les stewart noir qui
ont le intervenir la sécurité ont été
accueillis seraient série de singe c'est
vrai ça le met grove à temps pour
chasser battu violence et à la
réputation liverpool et on sait pas si
vous avez des gens
monsieur d'accord avec moi au gary
témoin direct de la
télé et la caisse que tomber à ça est ce
que vous me condamnez pas les anglais
bardella nous voilà c'est sérieux là
survient
d'après le monde la
saison la casse
évidemment je condamne ou accident c'est
pas une seconde à condamner ces les
enfants que je veux qu'on aime ce genre
très bien mais les anglais sting
reconnaissait mais ce qui me scandalise
c'est qu'on plante sous le tapis les
agressions qu'il ya eu à la sortie du
stade ces cinq sujets et le sujet c'est
pourquoi est-ce que ministre de
l'intérieur non par la nuit il est
chargé une à six personnes jugées vous
en fait une affaire d'état ils ont été
mis en garde et pourquoi
le chiffre est minime ce qui dérange
c'est les mauvais chiffres et les
chiffres qu'ils ont apparemment fou oui
mais non c'est bardé là c'est pas ça lui
je sais j'ai vu les joueurs alors je
suis vraiment je suis un temps fou et
j'ai vu des grands joueurs des légendes
du football enfin je sais pas parce que
je les connais pas mais j'ai vu des
grands joueurs de foot mag a expliqué
des jeux ou encore de belles années
expliqué que dargaud 91 et goa n'était
pas tenable donc si même dégradé la
gendarmerie disent que le chiffre ne
tient pas j'ai un moment donné on ne
peut pas minimiser les faits non plus
donc ils impriment de sécurité en france
et ne voir que le problème de
billetterie effectivement il ya eu
défaut bien mais c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est que en seine saint denis la
sécurité n'est plus assurée et que ce
qu'ont subi ce soir les supporters c'est
ce que subissent les habitants de la
seine-saint-denis au quotidien
maintenant compris certains mots gentils
liste idéale en mariage concernant
d'indochine de chine c'est au même
endroit il ya rien
je suis ici c'est qu'un tunnel de ce nom
il ya eu un entretien d'une personne qui
a assisté à tout ça qui a pris le métro
pour rentrer en ile de france a fait à
paris au centre d'observer un français
qui est rentré sur paris et juste après
le match et c'est là qu'il a raconté
qu'il était très blessée de voir qu'on
attaque et les gens dans le métro et ses
amis donc ça n'a rien à voir avec la
semaine passée les enfants sur ces les
anglais bien sûr et oui alors entre les
anglais qui sont les miens la sécurité
c'est le passé de l'attiser l'aviation
stéphane fonctionnent ces fadas mais on
peut aller regarder précisément ce qui
s'est passé à toutes les tables tout
pendant toutes les étapes de cette
soirée où l'on peut regarder ça on peut
on peut regarder effectivement ce qui
s'est passé à la sortie du rer on peut
regarder ce qui s'est passé dans les
dispositifs de pré filtrage moi j'étais
comme comme syrie au stade je me suis
retrouvé avec deux types qui n'avait
rien à voir avec en seine-saint-denis
dans une dans une file d'attenté où il y
avait un peu de personnes il y avait
deux il y avait très peu de personnes y
avait très peu paiera mais c'est sûr il
commenté
comment ils ont pu s'y infiltrer alors
il n'y a pas eu de filtrage à l'entrée
de ses films datant des filtres à qui
est ce que c'est mais vous avez la
passion des gens qui ont donc il faudra
bien interrogés y compris l'uefa qui
étaient là des sables de ce qui se
passait à l'extérieur du stade et sur
les compétences qu'elle a mobilisé ou
pas et si elle en attaque on s'était
mobilisé suffisamment pour justement
pour filtrer organiser au mieux en mieux
alors il faut que la mayonnaise que la
façade - depuis n'allait pas dans le
boulot pas de s'attacher il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont d'accord avec vous
aussi qui sont pas d'accord avec vous
oui oui mais c'est sa position elle
divise pas ce qu'on dit vous faites de
la politique vous soutenez monsieur
napoli qui n'ont même pas du tout les
galas du tour jeudi en
hausse et les anglais
n'ont quand même pas ce pas monsieur
barbe et là vous avez vu ce que les
anglais ont fait dans la fan zone où ils
étaient des dizaines de milliers inseme
ils ont laissé un champ de détritus
total
ils ont laissé sont visualisées gens là
sont venus pour filer paris.la avec des
faux billets
valides au pied de la tour eiffel ils
foutent le bordel au
st denis
et c'était les madrilènes maintenant
mais les familles ayant à toulouse elle
se souvenait bien passé avec les
habitants de saint denis et avec les
madrilènes pour exactement rassemblés
dans la salle où ils doivent répondre
c'est l'associé temps dit on est la
risée du monde
en fait on est la risée les on est la
risée du super que de l'étranger quand
la presse internationale qui plus
objectif que la presse française voit
ces images se dit mic mais qu'est ce
qu'est devenue la france et d'ailleurs
il faut quand même se rappeler que cet
événement a été organisé
en sanction à poutine parce que ça
devait avoir lieu à saint-etienne où et
quand certains franchement bravo le
résultat c'est qu'on a délocalisé la
finale ici pour un tel résultat qui est
aussi incroyable et on s'est battu pour
l'avoir et pour l'organiser donc ça veut
dire que le gouvernement est incapable
d'organiser le monde ça craint pour les
jeux olympiques 2024 et
l'art est largement sous-estimée et 6 en
trois mois on peut pas organiser un
match de foot alors faut compliqué alors
parce que si on lécher le c en a tout le
monde le fernand général et oui y
compris les russes il avait il avait eu
18 mois pour l'organiser pas moi c'est
ça bon mais ça n'excuse pas
ses plans dès qu'on va parler des
espagnols n'y a pas eu de problème dans
ce pagne ya rien s'il avait les billets
électroniques êtes d'accord
la réalité a battu à brive sam raimi et
dans la presse espagnole il ya plein de
gens qui se plaignent d'avoir été
agressé après aussi croire jeu et je
suis assez d'accord et il ya des gens
qui ont été traumatisés sur un ca vous
lisez les témoignages qui sont rapportés
dans la presse espagnole moi j'en ai lu
tout le week-end c'est traumatisant des
régions a été pris à partie en bande on
leur a craché dessus on les a insultés
on a cassé les vitres de leur voiture
c'est ce qui s'est passé est du délire
et probablement que les gens qui étaient
là et qui sont venus faire leurs courses
étaient des gens notamment les migrants
de la porte de la chapelle qui sont
venus c'est pas moi qui lis et les
policiers qu'il le dise donc on voit
bien qu'ils aient une situation qui
aujourd'hui hors de contrôle en
seine-saint-denis quoi qu'on en dise en
matière d'immigration également en vive
et les minerais la roue qui sont là mais
non je la tenais à pas changé pour moi
je dis vive elle-même vous savez
pourquoi je les vis plaît mais moi parce
que j'ai grandi pendant 20 ans et que
quand il s'est engagé en politique
internationale à l'époque et j'ai été
menacé de mort et j'ai dû quitter un
homme la syrie j'ai grandi puis
redescend et d'une mémoire mais trois
codage écran là c'est 4000 à la
courneuve le mythique et je vis encore
alors on peut imaginer le gamin et mes
deux gamins ils sont ils ont toujours
été scandés c'est la santé c'est
formidable s'est remis d'aplomb nous
laisse que voulaient les cieux des
salles et nous ne vous emmène en même
temps et c'est bien celle ci le trafic
de drogue mais voyez vous revenez à
votre obsession habituel est comme ça
mais ça repart une obsession monsieur
dallo fait beaucoup d'habits les on a
seulement parlé ce darmanin et monsieur
l'allemand grâce à vous ils peuvent
dormir tranquilles sur l'organisation de
cette soirée parce qu'en fait votre
seule obsession c'est la seine saint
denis qui rend demain quand on en a
marre compte tout le reste tout le reste
ou cette soirée était un fiasco un cias
qu en termes d'organisation
en termes de transport un cias qu en
termes de jean pas au bar former
les les entreprises qui filtrait tout ça
a été un fiasco mais vouloir demander la
billetterie 1 qui agressent les dans
l'eure